i the first thing i found was the idea
of water
being lobbed you know because water
love like water has no shape and it can
take the shape of whatever you pour it
into
they're very common people doing
extraordinary things
you know but their feelings are
recognizable you know they are
pure but we recognize ourselves in them
i mean the entire canon of shakespeare
didn't change the [ __ ] world
it didn't it just maybe made it a more
palatable place to be because you can
read it we still have corruption
destruction
abuse you know so you have to really
think look art is just
a nice thing to stay alive
so the advice is if you want to direct
direct and
even easier if you want to write
right show us don't tell us you know
do the things and if you do them wrong
but you're doing in your own terms
that's how i define success
failing in your own terms
the seed of the movie i think dates back
to when you were six years old and you
watched creature from the lagoon for the
first time you fell in love with both
judy adams
and the creature yeah and you wish
they'd got off together
yes yeah i was a kid and i didn't know
better and i thought
oh gee i hope they end up together and
you know
and they didn't and i i
i i thought it was a completely unfair
movie
because it's basically a home invasion
you know you have this creature living
peacefully in
his river and these [ __ ] come in in
a boat
invade his house and kill him and you go
this poor bastard was in his slippers
having a good time at home and these
guys come in and
hey we want to study you hey i don't
want to be started
okay you know and i thought uh i would
rectify that
you know and i thought all i knew
is i wanted to make the straight guy
with the gun and the nice suit and the
square jaw the villain
and i wanted to have the moment where
the creature carries
uh the girl a moment of not a horror
movie but a beautiful
moment of love he's a big fan i'm trying
when i try to explain to
non-fans with the movies i always tell
them that these are creatures and
monsters that have personalities
is that the secret that what makes this
whole thing work i think so because
each of them represents something in us
i mean hellboy is incredibly
recognizable for any male
you know he's a very male essential
figure abe
is uh almost like an intellect and the
spiritual
entity of the movie unless i hope is
recognizable as a as a female
trying to deal with a completely
irresponsible male partner
so and jochen is the rationale the the
logic
and so on and so forth you recognize
these people
and the clue to their hearts
is that they are very common they're
very
common people doing extraordinary things
you know but their feelings are
recognizable
you know they are pure but we recognize
ourselves in them i saw sally hawkins on
a
bbc series called fingersmith which was
remarkable
and she fell in love with a woman uh in
the series in victorian times
and i loved it because the fact that
they loved each other and they were the
same gender
was just a fact it was not the point
of the series it was just a fact and i
thought this is so beautiful
you know it's like the creature in her
make love physically but that's not the
point of the movie
it's just a fact and one night i don't
go to parties in hollywood i hate them
because it's like they're not even
parties
is everybody you avoided during the year
together in one place you know and uh
and
and but alfonso alfonso calls me and
says
alejandra and i are going to the golden
globes party and i go okay
i'm watching antics roadshow
and so i arrive and i say okay are we
going to get [ __ ] face like yeah yeah
yeah we're going to get [ __ ] raised
okay great so i go i'm going to start
and i'll catch up with you and i have 14
shots of tequila
i hate this i hate the flavor and i go
okay
now we can start i go on and say
alejandro okay we're ready he says
oh no you know what we're not going to
drink what
so i said i'm going to leave so i'm
leaving with my 14 shots of tequila and
me
and i see sally and i go hey
i go i'm writing a movie for you where
you fall in love with a fish
[Applause]
and she says great
i said to her look i want to do a beauty
and the beast where beauty is not a
disney princess where she makes
breakfast shines her shoes and
masturbates and
and the beast doesn't turn into a
[ __ ] prince you know
because i i think love is about
loving who the other person is exactly
if you need change go away
please go away you know don't waste
anybody's time
and i thought it could be about
embracing and loving the otherness
which my entire career has been about
but i could finally phrase it in a way
that i felt was magical for lack of a
better
uh term and you know i i felt
i needed to find a way to make it be
about something
that used that and then little by little
i the first thing i found was the idea
of water
being lobbed you know because water
love like water has no shape and it can
take the shape of whatever you're
pouring into
you can fall in love with somebody that
is twice your age
same gender a completely opposite
religion
a completely wrong political persuasion
it just happens
and and it is like water the most
powerful and malleable
element in the universe you're feeling
good about shape of water aren't you
i do because i mean the way you go on
making movies for
everybody is a filmography for you is a
biography
and the moment i chose to do shape which
would be seen by many as a completely
insane unsure
bet against continuing doing
bigger movies which were already on
their way
but it was a very personal decision at a
very crucial point of my personal life
and i said
i'm 52 let's go where it's not safe
you know let's go there because and i
think those are the genuine moments
as a storyteller where you find so to
speak the gold
so mimic was your first american
experience
which you sort of fought and lost i
my first american experience was almost
my last experience because it was with
the
weinsteins at miramax and i can tell you
two horrible things happen in the late
90s my father was kidnapped and i worked
with the weinsteins
it's and i don't know which one was
worse actually the kidnapping made more
sense
because i knew what they wanted you know
and uh and uh
i really hated the experience but i
learned to fight
and two things that happened that were
positive on mimic
i lost casting battles i lost
story battles i lost my battles but the
one thing mimic is and
100 is visually exactly what i wanted
our direction camera moves color palette
cinematography and i realized okay
i learned that and i learned a lot more
and really
on mimik i learned to move the camera
in a really beautiful choreography with
the
the actors because bob weinstein was
always saying why don't you move the
camera you never move the camera okay
i'm going to move the camera
but i'm going to move the camera the way
i want it and i i devised this idea
of counter movements for the auburns and
that's the way i should now without that
experience i would have not progressed
uh much and and the movie is visually
gorgeous and it has
a couple of sequences i'm very very
proud of you know
and i remember on our first one of our
first meetings
they said you know the only rule you got
to follow is you cannot harm kids or
pets
so i had one scene where i killed two
kids and one dog
and you know i don't know if this is
much of an achievement but it felt good
and and then the movie the movie get
actually very well reviewed
for a giant cockroach movie and
and uh after that i had met pedro
almodovar at the end of the
tour of chronos and pedro moldova had
said to me
i love your movie if i if
if you can come to spain we will produce
something for me you know i i when uh
when anyone
uh approaches me and says i want to be a
director
i i i always tell them then you should
just be
a director and and don't say i'm going
to be because
you can direct good or bad but you can
direct
from your iphone from your cell phone
with your
sister's cousin video camera with a
webcam
with right now except in the most
object circumstances most people can get
a hold
of an image audio visual generating
machine
and they can be directing and then
realize that they are already directing
directing should doesn't mean anymore
and shouldn't mean anymore
directing feature films i think that
as i said with series like breaking bad
i i was not only amazed at the way it
was written but the way it was
uh staged on camera it was a really well
directed
series and and video games also can do
that and i
i think that so as long as you have you
have minimal access to any media
you should be a director if you feel
like you
you want to and the advice i feel is
that
it's always better to to
answer through your work the things you
don't like in a media
in a piece of media if you dislike the
movies that are being made
make your own show the world what you
want to do what you think this medium
should be
and and i find that much more creative
than
simply putting it down and complaining
about it is a more active
fascinating role to take so the advice
is if you want to direct
direct and even easier if you want to
write
right you know i think that
writing is the only one of the only
things that can be done with very little
resources and even if you die and you
were unpublished you
still have a chance you know it's truly
you cannot do that with directing
you need other people you need a little
bit of help you need
at least an actor in front of the camera
you know but but i think these are
what i say is go and do it and and you
know when they say
oh i would like you to to do this for me
or
and i produce a lot of first-time
filmmakers
but i don't produce old first-time
filmmakers that approach me and i say
look
if i say no and you give up
i'm sorry to tell you but it's the wrong
job for you
because you live with rejection for
decades
sometimes as a director and you end up
making the movie you want to make
so if i say no that doesn't mean i'm
right
or i'm wrong you just say [ __ ] him i'll
show him later
you know i'm gonna make it and that fat
bastard is gonna
have to say i was so wrong and
hit himself in the head because he
didn't do it and i think that that's the
thing to do is like
show us don't tell us you know do the
things
and if you do them wrong but you're
doing in your own terms that's how i
define success
failing in your own terms well look to
me
it's a strange profession we chose as
directors because
it's a combination of being tough as
nails
and being as permeable and fragile as
you can
and you need to sort of separate the two
you cannot be completely fragile because
then you won't make movies
you can use to become a poet or a
painter you know
because a filmmaker is never gonna die
and they're gonna find a drawer full of
movies that he never did
and oh my god and it's gonna be on dvd
and blu-ray it won't be
you know you have to be a tough
[ __ ] to get into the business
side and fight
and tell the bastards no no and i'm no i
won't do it i'll do it my way
a lot of fights so you have to be tough
in that and you have to fight and
be able to defend what the movie needs
to be defended and then at the same time
you need to be incredibly
incredibly permeable and fragile and for
example
you can be screaming at your producer
one moment about the crane not being
ready and then you have to be
completely open with your actor to watch
the actor perform
how would you describe it a fairy tale
for troubled times
well we got the troubled times well i
think i think that what it is
is a moment right now and that's why i
chose 62 because
we're echoing 62 in a really
intriguing way you know we are uh at a
time
cold war is on again first of all but
there's also
a time that is very divisive and
it's very divisive partially because the
image of the camelot america the ideal
america the america that was great
is crystallized in 62 before kennedy
gets uh murdered
assassinated before vietnam escalates
uh and it's it's crystallized in this
backyard suburban barbecue jet fit cars
myth but if you go back in time like we
do in the movie
you see it's a very divisive time and
it's about the other the movie is about
empathy with the other a lot of people
confuse
what i like with what i do and they say
well guillermo likes
artur macken or he likes edwin dulac
or lord duncany yes you know and how
does
the pan of mac and reflect on his work
or how they lack
they don't it's not an equipment i don't
see that actually well it's not it's not
a
plus plus plus equals
but as writer i do not read them as
research no
because then you are you're deciphering
too much exactly
and i think it's better to do it free
flow free form
and to let it come right it's just uh i
take from macken for example the awe
of the ancient forests yes which is
pagan
but you only take it because there's
already something in you stirring and
understanding you'll never be
you're not right i don't think you take
anything from the world that you don't
already have no
we find our tribe we find what fits us
we wheel it into being
yes but yes it's also from lord duncan
i take the spirit the sort of poetic
spirit of his fairy tales
for example on pants the title of one of
his best books
the king of elf land's daughter it's a
beautiful book
completely different but i remember the
title itself
said oh i said that's a feeling i think
magical realism is a classification that
comes from outside
the phenomena and every time we school
something we're kind of lying to
understand it we're pigeonholing it
and we group some of the latin american
boom in the same package but they're so
different
some of them are so european so to me
it's not so much a literary school as
having
born in the place you were born i'll
explain that simply
you are what you are and that's what you
bring to the movies you make
it doesn't all we can do as artists is
the synthesis of something that has been
done before
we're 2 000 years in at least
in civilization every song has been sung
every story has been told
but your voice hasn't been heard
your voice is yet to be heard and in
that i package
two things that are one and the same
your qualities and your defects
and as a latin american the way i live
it
we could be having dinner and somebody
says i saw a ghost and they say oh yeah
pass the bread
you know it doesn't [ __ ] matter you
know
i saw sure you did my grandmother came
to visit me last night and told me a
secret from heaven sure
where's the salsa
magic and realism in mexico same thing
same thing brilliant that's why bunuel
went to mexico and said this is the most
surreal country in the world because
it's absolutely true and that's why
uh what an european would qualify as an
absurdist
thing is what is natural to me you take
the things that are more extraordinary
and you root them in the ordinary
the conflation of those two things and
if you uh come from a european or
anglo-saxon point of view
these things are different tonally but
for a mexican
it's second nature you know we are alter
makers
you give me five genres and i'll
organize them in a certain shape and
i'll make a little altar
crazy it's going to have a you know like
magpies
we find a shiny object and accommodate
next to a less shiny object
and we construct things and that's
synthesis by the way
that's what is new nobody has organized
those shiny bids the way you do
you